welcome back World War two 9/11 and now
kovat nineteen major events forcing the
New York Stock Exchange to close its
floor trading and that is where we find
ourselves today that is the deal
beginning Monday but the exchange will
be open for electronic trading so how's
it going to impact everyday investors
joining us right now to talk more about
that we talked with the president of the
New York Stock Exchange Stacey
Cunningham Stacey thanks very much for
joining me once again this is a big deal
closing the trading floor for a period
of time what are your expectations you
know it is a big deal Maria we haven't
closed the trading floor as you
mentioned through theirs there are a few
historic moments where the trading floor
has been closed what's different about
this time is that electronic trading
will continue so that part of it is
different we run multiple markets we run
five equity exchanges to options markets
many of them trade fully electronically
the New York Stock Exchange introduces
the human judgment element on top of
stock trading that leads to dampening
volatility during times of stress and as
we've seen lately the markets have been
pretty volatile so we were hanging on to
try and keep that extra added protection
on into the market but it got to a point
where we just were concerned we could we
couldn't guarantee that people were
going to be be able to be protected
their health so while we're seeing how
the virus unfolds and steps that we can
continue to take we're temporarily
shifting to fold electronic until we can
get that have more clarity around that
situation so what are your expectations
in terms of how long this lasts Stacey
when we spoke earlier this week on Fox
Business on mornings with Maria you said
look if there's a situation where we
need human interaction where we need
that extra you know buying or selling to
balance out a trade we have it here on
the floor of the NYC are you worried
that you will not have that component
now with electronic trading only I do
think we'll see some added volatility
I'll give you an example last Friday
when the president announced that he was
going to fill the oil reserves it was
just a few minutes before the closing
auction and we saw massive buy orders
coming into the into the market right at
that close the traders here on the floor
were able to go solicit offsetting sell
orders so that they could dampen
that volatility or reduced-price swings
and so that that's an important function
that they're able to deliver when we go
fully electronic you don't see that same
effect so yes I do think it's gonna add
to a little bit of additional volatility
and it already volatile period of time
so that's concerning from an Operations
perspective I have confident it'll work
smoothly so stocks will still open and
close traders will still be able to send
their their interest in and and and
things will trade normally I just expect
you're gonna see additional volatility
around the edges and that's unfortunate
given how the markets are already you
know it's dealing with so many price
swings Stacey let me move away from the
operations of this because we clearly
understand why you're closing the
trading floor for a temporary period of
time you know you've got what a couple
hundred people on the floor right now
yeah there are a few hundred people and
I will say this is a very patriotic
group Maria so they're looking to come
back is that as possible they want to do
their right right and you know they
understand the value and service they
provide to investors as we all do and
and of course so put that aside for a
moment want to ask you something about
sentiment because you've been on the
floor for years before you had this role
of president you were there in the
trenches on the floor of the exchange
what is your take on sentiment
particularly today as the president
started talking about vaccines talking
more about cures and about therapies to
treat coronavirus we saw the market
change direction we saw the market
actually trade up and finish up 188
points on the Dow Jones Industrial
Average about 1% do you feel a change in
sentiment on the floor because we've
lost 7 trillion dollars in market value
I'm wondering where the sentiment goes
now Stacey yes I mean markets react
uncertainty as you know well right and
so what we've been trying to understand
is how is how is this virus pandemic
going to continue to unfold what's the
long-term impact going to be on
Americans in their everyday lives and I
think what we're seeing is the
government rising to the occasion to
answer some of those questions these are
the things that they're going to do I've
had the opportunity you know over the
past couple of weeks to talk to the
federal administration through to the
Treasury Department to the House
Financial Services Committee to our
regulator
to local city and state government
government and all of them are very
focused on helping those in need and and
I think that you'll see you know the
through the stimulus package and the
announcements that the president
continues to make there is a lot of
interest addressing the short-term pain
on the on the economy and so that's
that's where I think you're seeing
market reaction it's a very chant you
know it's a changing moment very fluid
every single day we get new news and
people are reacting to that in real time
yeah real quick Stacy do you want to see
any other changes in terms of the
regulations over financial services and
the new york stock exchange because the
president's doing fast-track at the fda
is there anything standing in the way in
terms of creating a more effective
trading situation for Wall Street that
you'd like to see from a regulatory
standpoint real quick yeah one thing I
will highlight because it's been rumored
a few times that there's talk of
shutting the markets down to stop stop
the market decline I have not had that
conversation with any of those groups I
talked about that they're not
considering it at Treasury at Congress
in any of those areas and I think that
that understanding that that's not the
case would be actually be helpful to
investor sentiment if people here the
market might be closed they may be more
inclined to sell if they're afraid they
won't be - and that's right so I think
hearing a clear statement which we have
heard from secretary minutiae and we
have heard from chairman Clayton at the
SES they have no plans to close the
market you're hearing it from me the
markets are staying open we're talking
about closing the markets we're not
talking about shortening the trading day
repeating that message I think is really
important for everyone to hear Stacy
thank you we will see you soon
appreciate it very much